on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-handed veteran kevin gausman
coming into his 33rd star in the years
had a tremendous season
and he bounces this one to crawford
crawford gets a big hop
and the inning is over
three up three down giants are coming up
it'll be lasella
to lead things off
on the hill today for the san diego
ponders will be the right-hander joe
musgrove musgrove 28 years of age he's
in his fifth year at the big league
level big guy six five two thirty this
is start number 31 he's had a solid
season for the padres 11-9 with a 3-2-2
era one strikeout away from the magic
number of 200 on the season against just
54 walks
one and two and he got him strikeout
number 200 on the season for joe
musgrove as ruff goes down swinging to
wrap up a perfect first
line drive down the right field line and
nobody's there
crawford's got a double
he almost hit it right at machado
so here's brian hit up the middle and a
base hit and here comes crawford
one-nothing giants
nothing more than a cni ground ball hit
him where they ain't
listed with their telephone numbers
that's a fair ball the other way for
fernando see if he tries to turn it into
another double he is
and no chance for us
to throw him out
second straight game with a double for
tatis number 31.
two down
dribbled
and gorsman bayer handed
ending over
good work by gosman
stranding chachis in second one nothing
giants
darren ruff leads off
last of the fourth inning
toward the middle
the long throw by kim
and infield a hit for darren ruff
swung on line drive right at manny
machado he snares it on the backhand for
the out he quickly looks over at second
base but darren ruff wisely
freezing on the line drive so no chance
to double him up
but another great reaction played by
manny machado to record the first out
here in the fourth inning certainly
spoiled watching
manny play third base and often overlook
plays that he makes look easy but
this is a rocket off the bat of chris
bryant
struck him out
second strikeout that was nasty osman
will try it again
struck him out and there's that high
tight fastball you were talking about
mike you can't put it in a better spot i
mean he goes 95 right above the hands
with two-seam movement
right to wade
it's very hard
one-nothing giants after four and a half
two and one to la stella and that's in
the air to left field mariznick gets
there and makes the diving catch
he has had himself a day defensively and
jake marisnick showing off the wheels
and the extension might need a new belt
but he makes the play to end the inning
a one two three
awesome going to the count
he's struck him out oh man
three nasty split finger fastballs
[Applause]
you can't throw better ones than that
and he knows he's got a good one he
locked into something
mechanically in denver he knew it when
it happened and that was 11th hit 29
career paths
against the right hand
it's a one out knock in the pinch for
adam frazier
tying run aboard now top of the order
coming up
popped him up
is it no man's land it is and fernando's
got his second hit of the day grisham
around the third
runners on the corners two outs
and the padres a little bit of a two-out
rally here you take him how you get him
manny machado coming up
and manny into left field that'll tie
the game
trent grisham on to score and it's 1-1
in the sixth
back-to-back two out hits by tatis and
machado
austin slater is the pitch hitter for
lamont wade
left center field still going still
going
[Applause]
down
that pinch hit home run over the 399
marker
by austin slater to put the giants right
back ahead
bosman thrones he struck him out anyway
came back with another splitter on the
outside that was up a little bit
this strikeout for gaza in all swing and
miss strike threes cued to crawford
crawford's going to go to the bag and
that'll end the inning
yes duggar casalli coming up
down a run in the eighth
and he fights that one off sends it into
center field for a lead off base hit
second straight inning the padres get
the lead off man to board and see if
they can get this one home
that's a fair ball down the right field
line ave gif is on his way to third base
he'll stop there grisham into second
with a double and the padres are in
business big time here in the eighth
and manny hits it in the air out to left
field playable for slater
we'll see garrett tagging garrett trying
to come home the throw not even close to
the game is tied
manny machado battled and battled and
battled against hotel and the pinch
runner reliever avi guerra comes in to
score it's two to two
first pitch swinging pro far into right
field and a lead off base hit
padres with a go ahead run
on base to start the ninth inning
that's ripped to left field in a base
hit from arizona
profar is taking a wide turn at second
but now retreating
as rough got it in quickly couple of
hits here against doval in the nine
and it went around and that is the end
of the inning
so here's machado
[Applause]
machado has both
runs batted in in this game and they're
going to walk him
of
the last two at-bats of any hitters in
this game he's had the best two at bats
[Applause]
jake cronenworth will get into the box
looking for his first hit of the day
waited on it and into right field for a
base hit the padres going to take the
lead carratini scores little bobble
yastremski and manny around a third on
the double by cronenworth and san diego
in front for the first time today
runner on third two outs padres by a run
two balls and two strikes
and flores popped up shallow center here
comes grisham and the padres win it
a 10-inning victory at oracle park in
san francisco and mark mullanson with
his 39th save of the season the giants
champagne will be kept on ice
they'll wait and see what happens with
the dodgers and brewers tonight but for
the moment no celebration in san
francisco